[Musique]
le chebana marquis à quelqu'un qui vaut
1 est quelqu'un qui est assis à côté qui
vaut cinq comptent six fois plus que
celui qui fait quand même le même
travail
alors bonjour je reviens vers vous
toujours pour notre notre dossier sur la
banane nationale ana alors auparavant un
tout petit rappel sur la censure dont
j'ai été l'objet de l'association est
les dom a été l'objet puisque france
antilles martinique nous a totalement
censuré il n'y a pas de doute là dessus
merci infiniment à toutes les
martiniquaises tous les martiniquais
tous les guadeloupéens également l'open
de est extrêmement nombreux quarante
mille ou 50000 vue qui se sont indignés
parce que c'est clairement une succube
pratique ça tient pas debout quoi peut
s'interroger de savoir d'ailleurs
pourquoi france antilles sur quelles
pressions france antilles la censure et
suivez mon regard je reviens vers vous
sur la banane est sûr pas la marte
alors oui ben ammar pourquoi parce que
ben ammar
on n'y est sûrement pas pour rien est en
train de faire le tour en ce moment des
petits producteurs pour voir ce qui ne
va pas découvre au bout de treize ans
que peut-être des choses qui vont pas
chez damart la première chose qui va pas
chez la marque c'est la représentativité
des petites exploitations et je vais
vous dire quelque chose qui est
incroyable c'est que selon que vous
soyez petit où que vous soyez plus gros
et bien
vous avez une représentativité très
différentes exemple si je suis un petit
producteur et je fais 100 tonnes de
bananes et bien je pèse une voix au
conseil d'administration de manama mais
si je suis un gros producteur et que je
suis assez malin pour avoir coupé en
tranches
ma production mais que j'ai par exemple
cette exploitation cas réels puisque
existants évidemment en martinique est
bien là j'ai pas ce que je fais plus que
un tonnage puisque milton g8 voient et
que faisait cette exploitation cette
fois 8 56 ça veut dire que chez banana
qui a quelqu'un qui vaut 1 est quelqu'un
qui est assis à côté qui vaut 56 fois
plus que celui qui fait quand même le
même travail donc c'est pas logique
domination professionnel ça c'est une
logique d'entreprise logique
d'actionnariat mais c'est pas une
logique d'organisation professionnelle
dans une ambition professionnelle un
égal 1-1 producteurs gagnent à notre
twitter et moi ce que j'ai dit
aujourd'hui à bas la marque
je vous dis messieurs de bâle à marthe
et bien fait le premier pas et si vous
voulez de l'équipe c'est la première
chose que vous faites vous changez vos
statuts de soi parce que un producteur
égale un producteur quel que soit le
nombre de tonnes qu'il produit dans une
année voilà je crois malheureusement pas
que vous le ferez
c'est pourquoi je dis il faut créer une
autre organisation professionnelle avec
les petits producteurs ou là on aura
bien un égal un chacun pourra faire
valoir sa voix se défendre dans le
système actuel les petits producteurs
n'ont aucun droit car ils n'ont aucune
représentativité sérieux je vous informe
également que suite aux nombreux appels
retours que nous avons lu nous avons
créé air et dom martinique donc
physiquement et rénove bartnik existe il
ya maintenant des gens qui se sont mis
derrière nous en appui élections très
courageuse c'était pas évident du tout
compte tenu des pressions tout le monde
connaît les pressions que en martinique
lorsque quelqu'un n'est pas d'accord et
surtout vient vers nous alors si vous
souhaitez adhérer
il existe et redouane martinique venait
que vous soyez planteurs vous êtes très
bienvenu évidemment les petits planteurs
de bananes sont très bienvenues chez les
hommes il y en a déjà qui sont chez nous
et ça c'est bien
merci mais aussi d'autres aussi bien des
particuliers aussi bien d'autres
entreprises parce que c'est ensemble
qu'on va arriver à lutter pour faire en
sorte que les monopoles lâche tous tout
ce capital qu'ils ont pris qu'ils ont
confirmé à leur seul profit et qu'on
puisse enfin permettre de trouver des
solutions légales des solutions
réglementaires qui vont permettre aux
tout petits d'avoir une chance de se
déployer à très bientôt pour une très
prochaine vidéo sur la banane j'ai
encore plein de choses à vous dire sur
le sujet à bientôt et adhérer chez les
dom
ensemble on est plus fort
[Musique]